[Music]
he's definitely ready for the fight a
bunch of good Fighters here he he's
swimming with the guys you know if you
if you can keep your head above water
you know in the sparing rounds um
rolling grappling strike him um then you
know he's going to do fine I'm sh Austin
um the head MMA coach at fight zone I'm
still a professional fighter and
obviously the head coach the gym for uh
the MMA program how's your training
going it's going all right I've lost
weight as you can see
1 there you go on the 14th of December
there's going to be some fireworks
that's going to take place in the centry
I'm going to make my professional MMA
debut and I'm going to take on a very
stiff and competent opponent a
boxer uh I've been training here with
some of the best heavyweights in the
country actually some of the coaches
here like Stuart Austin who's only the
only person's ever beaten Tom Aspen
who's a UFC heavyweight champion I think
someone else might have had like a DQ in
or something um he's got a fantastic
record and now he's a coach we've got
Mario Pinto who's also UFC heavyweight
trading with and also he's like a coach
so he's like a tra training partner
coach uh 9 and0 professional record
undefeated and of course we've got
shaani as as well who's a up and come
bangi person heavyweight 4 and0 and he's
got a fight coming up as well in
December so we've got the team I'm very
privileged to be with people like this
and this much
experience I'm hoping that it's going to
be a fantastic uh day on the 14th
actually so make sure that you book the
pay-per-view tickets cuz you watch this
on pay-per-view 20% 1 of the earnings
will go to charity we go to the Lebanese
crisis we know what's going on there and
so we can inallah raise money and be
entertained at the same time